[Applaus]
[Musik]
netflix prime video disney glas die
video und die man plattformen sind alle
am boden
der wettbewerb ist hart und jeden tag
mehr und mehr streaming plattformen
darum ihr stück am kuchen zu vergrößern
neue abonnenten zu gewinnen und der
konkurrenz marktanteile abzunehmen
dieses phänomen trägt ihre ausgaben für
neue inhalte in immer neue sphären es
wird geschätzt dass die investition in
neue video inhalte bis ende 2022
weltweit 230 milliarden dollar
übersteigen könnten und diese
entwicklung trage natürlich in erster
linie video on demand plattformen allein
der branchenführer netflix will in
diesem jahr 19 milliarden dollar in neue
inhalte stecken ja richtig gehört 19
milliarden dollar nur netflix
[Musik]
außerdem handelt es sich um ein
investitions niveau das nicht als
einmaliges oder außergewöhnliches
ereignis betrachtet werden kann
angesichts des enormen wettbewerbs in
der branche sind die streaming anbieter
gezwungen immer mehr für neue inhalte
auszugeben um ihre abonnenten zu halten
der punkt dabei ist nur der zeit erzählt
praktisch keine dieser plattformen einen
positiven cashflow und genau das erklärt
schlagzeilen wie diese
disney netflix apple gewinnt jemand den
streaming creek die investoren haben
angst dass sich der preis am ende nicht
rechnet am rande dieses erbitterten
kampfes gibt es jedoch noch eine andere
streaming plattform die sich still und
leise an die spitze der branche setzt
ich spreche von niemandem geringeren als
jener plattform auf der ihr gerade
dieses video seht ihr youtube myvideo
abteilung von alfabet bricht immer neue
rekorde mit ihrem kostenlosen
nutzungsmodell und einigen
kostenpflichtigen angeboten gelegt ist
ihr die größten plattformen in sachen
umsatz zu schlagen schaut euch einfach
mal selbst an
allein im vierten quartal 2021 hat
youtube mehr als 8,6 milliarden dollar
für werbung ausgegeben ohne die
kostenpflichtigen dienste zu
berücksichtigen die es bereits anbietet
und die alfabet vorerst nicht
aufschlüsseln dennoch allein mit ihren
werbeeinnahmen konnte youtube die rund
7,7 lehrern dollar welche die derzeitige
nummer 1 oder den video und demand
plattformen nämlich netflix selben
zeitraum eingenommen hat bei weitem
übertreffen insgesamt hat youtube im
jahr 2021 was 30 milliarden dollar an
werbung eingenommen und hält damit die
konstanten jährlichen wachstumsraten von
über 30 prozent aufrecht lasst euch das
mal auf der zunge zergehen 30 prozent
wachstum über viele viele jahre hinweg
das ist einfach nur noch pokal diese
zahl drückt im grunde genommen aus wie
die medialen herrscher der vergangenen
60 jahre die fernsehsender ohne
jegliches abkommen ohne chance
niedergewalzt werden und was noch
wichtiger ist youtube hat diese enormen
zahlen erreicht ohne die riesigen
investitionen inhalte tätigen zu müssen
zu denen die anderen plattformen
gezwungen waren
[Musik]
du kannst sie also vorstellen dass er in
diesem fall heute über viel größere
gewinnspannen sprechen selbst wenn wir
die zahlungen von youtube an die
ersteller der inhalte berücksichtigen
einige analysten weisen zum beispiel
darauf hin dass der anteil des durch
youtube generierten cashflows an den
gesamteinnahmen weit über 30 prozent
liegen würde tja das ist wahrlich nicht
schlecht für ein unternehmen das
alphabet damals noch google im jahr 2006
für nur 1,65 milliarden dollar
übernommen hat oder damals schien dies
viel geld rückblickend lässt sich jedoch
um ein geniales schnäppchen das sich zu
einem koloss entwickelt hat einen koloss
der aber noch lange nicht am ende seines
wachstums angelangt ist im gegenteil
vielleicht ist dies alles erst der
anfang die frage lautet also welche
großen pläne hat alfabet noch für
youtube in der schublade schnallt euch
an den diesem video geht es auch um die
mediale zukunft von uns allen eine
zukunft die maßgeblich durch die von uns
genutzten medien und
informationsplattformen geprägt sein
wird und nur wer sich in dieser medialen
zukunft zurechtfinden wird wird die welt
noch verstehen bevor wir jedoch loslegen
müssen wir uns bei unserem sponsor surf
schlag bedanken der dieses video möglich
gemacht hat so stark ist ein wirklich
sicheres vpn dass weder datenverkehr
noch beta oder verbindungsdaten mittwoch
den anonymität und sicherheit im netz
sind ein sehr kostbares gut es bietet
unzählige sicherheitsfeatures zum
beispiel clean web dass alle cookies pop
aus und auch fortgeschrittene
identifizierungs und nach
wirkungsmechanismen von denen man oft
gar nicht sicher bloggt und die damit
verbundene gefahren beseitigt natürlich
könnt ihr mit dessen hilfe auch website
internetdiensten zu greifen im land den
weg des itunes verfügbar sind ohne
zensur und walking ob daheim oder im
urlaub netflix und andere streaming
dienste ihre inhalte nur in den usa
anbieten von europa aus nutzen mit
surfer kein problem aber nicht nur das
mit nur einem surfer grund da könnt ihr
alle eure geräte im vgn registrieren
handys notebooks oder sogar eure smart
tvs deckt wirklich alle arten von
geräten ab ihr bekommt damit einen
lückenlosen schutz so und wenn ihr den
rabattcode politik.de angibt bekommt ihr
von surf schlag auch noch einen rabatt
in höhe von 83 prozent und obendrein die
ersten drei monate gratis dazu denn hin
zu diesem angebot findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video also
nicht wehrlos besorgt aussagekraft damit
gleichen die uns finanziell unter die
arme wir sind euch für jede
unterstützung dankbar denn damit hätte
er uns auch in zukunft noch mehr und
noch besser videos zu liefern das könnt
ihr übrigens auch direkt mit hilfe des
pk spenden links den ich euch ebenfalls
die beschreibung gepackt haben so und
nun lasst uns schnell wieder zum thema
dieses videos zurückkommen unsere frage
welche großen pläne hegt alfabet noch
mit youtube also los geht's
[Musik]
epizentrum der dienste
youtube hat zurzeit mehr als zwei
milliarden aktive nutzer das heißt fast
ein viertel der gesamten weltbevölkerung
genutzt diese plattform kein anderer
dienst kommt auch nur annähernd an diese
zahl heran jeden tag werden mehr als
fünf milliarden videos abgespielt und es
wird geschätzt dass etwa 25 prozent des
gesamten weltweiten mobilen
datenverkehrs auf dieser plattform
stattfinden ja das ist ziemlich verrückt
in den usa zum beispiel nutzt die
mehrheit der bevölkerung diesen dienst
mindestens einmal pro woche und das gilt
für alle altersgruppen inklusive der
buba
und wie du dir vorstellen kannst stellt
dies natürlich ein riesiges potenzial da
und bietet enorme cross selling
möglichkeiten ein vorteil des alphabets
essen will um die zahl der bezahlten
abonnements zu erhöhen die
hauptinstrumente dieser strategie heißt
wie youtube premium youtube music und
youtube tv diese versammlung bereits
mehr als 53 millionen zahlende
abonnenten drei dienste mit dem youtube
bereits 2,3 milliarden dollar pro
quartal einnehmen könnte wenn wir diese
zahl also zu den werbeeinnahmen an die
in die wir zuvor gesehen haben könnte
youtube pro quartal fast elf milliarden
dollar einnehmen das sind 40 prozent
mehr als netflix und das bedeutet im
klartext youtube netflix deklassieren
und vielleicht sogar stürzen tatsächlich
ist die youtube musik dafür schon recht
repräsentativ youtube kam in diesem
markt recht spät und spotify apple music
und emi music hatten ihn bereits
gesättigt ja aber trotz allem läuft ist
für youtube music ziemlich gut
youtube musikdienste erreichen 50
millionen abonnenten und hohen spotify
ein die google eigene plattform zu einem
ernsthaften konkurrenten und versucht
gleichzeitig die beziehungen zu den
großen musiklabels zu verbessern um euch
eine vorstellung zu geben falls dieser
dies 2018 eingeführt wurde waren die
analysten skeptisch morgan stanley zum
beispiel schätzt dass dieser dienst mit
einer optimistischen prognose bereits
ende 2022 25 millionen abonnenten
erreichen könnte wie wir gesehen haben
war die realität aber ganz anders
[Musik]
mitte 2000 21 hatte youtube musikpreisen
die als 50 millionen zahlenden
abonnenten allein zwischen september 20
und 21 ist die zahl der zahlenden
abonnenten von youtube musik um mehr als
60 prozent gestiegen
[Musik]
youtube musik bleibt für die generation
sie zu dem was spotify für die
millennials vor einem halben jahrzehnt
war
denn laut daten die lacko und ein
abteilungsleiter der financial times
verfügung gestellt hat würden die musik
schaffen unter berücksichtigung der
bergung des anteils an den abo zahlungen
die sie einnehmen mehr als vier
milliarden dollar pro jahr von youtube
erhalten verglichen mit den rund 5
milliarden dollar die spotify an die
zeit wo es polizei dreimal so viele
abonnenten hat und dass es in der tat
ein weiterer großer vorteil den die
youtube zentrale ist an krone ausnutzen
will um weiter marktanteile in der musik
streaming große zu gewinnen zivil viele
einnahmen für die urheber generieren mir
werden übrigens oft gefragt warum wir
keinen visual politik podcast oder
spotify anbieten die antwort ist ganz
klar spotify ist im gegensatz zu youtube
nicht in der lage uns als content
creator ein konkurrenzfähiges und
tragfähiges geschäftsmodell anzubieten
sogar minister wissen togo hat darüber
mal ein video gemacht eine weitere
wachstums formel die youtube in betracht
ziehen könnte ist der kauf von produkten
direkt auf der plattform während ein
video abgespielt wird natürlich gegen
eine saftige provision dieses modell
wird auf dem asiatischen markt immer
beliebter und könnte früher oder später
auch diese plattform erreichen mit
anderen worten youtube will jetzt seine
riesige zahl an aktiven nutzern
verwerten um neue geschäftsmodelle zu
entwickeln und ein wichtiger akteur im
video und musik streaming zu werden und
genau das ist es was ich momentan im
innenleben des giganten youtube abspielt
der extremen krieg oft übersehen wird
aber dennoch das größte stück vom kuchen
abbekommen könnte denn dem sieger nichts
geringeres als die mediale zukunft
gehören
[Musik]
und genau das werden die
marktmechanismen sein die darüber
bestimmen werden welche informationen in
unsere köpfe gelangen und welche nicht
der umbruch ist bereits gelaufen aber
erst nach und nach wird es sich in
seiner göttlichen absolutheit
manifestieren und es ist klar dass nur
diejenigen gewinnen werden die sich in
dieser neuen welt optimal orientieren
können in diesen neuen paradigmen denken
und handeln wir werden ja in den
kommentaren immer wieder gefragt wieso
unsere analysen und vorhersagen immer so
ins schwarze treffen woher der
eigentlich so viel hintergrundwissen
haben und wie wir dies so gut in größere
zusammenhänge stellen können nun eine
recht überraschende antwort darauf
könnte sein niemand in unserer redaktion
besitzt einen fernseher und das schon
seit vielen jahren das letzte mal dass
ich eine glosse mit fernsehempfang hatte
ist 24 jahre her neulich fragte mich
jemand was ich davon halten würde was
irgendeinen fernseh philosoph
namensrecht in irgend einer talkshow
gesagt hätte gut aus dem theater kannte
ich brecht einen zeitlosen dramatiker
und ich dachte zunächst es handele sich
um einen logopäden witz charme und
beißen aber dann musste ich doch zugeben
dass ich eigentlich gar nicht wisse was
ein fernseh philosoph sein soll und dass
dies für mich einfach nur
anachronistische dinge sind klasse
vernebelte kindheitserinnerungen aus
einer längst vergangenen zeit daher
empfinde ich es als zeitverschwendung
sich mit irrelevanten relikten dieser
art zu beschäftigen wenn wir uns doch
mit unserer zukunft beschäftigen und
diese auch medial kompetent gestalten
wollen aber gut jetzt seid ihr erst mal
an der reihe meine lieben experten
hattet ihr eine vorstellung davon dass
youtube bereits heute so groß ist und so
was es noch heranwachsen könnte wie
denkt ihr wird dieses zukunft unser
leben unsere bildung und unsere mediale
kompetenz beeinflussen wie immer sind
wir auf eure kommentare schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat und jeder weiß
vielleicht auch etwas gelernt habt falls
ja gibt uns bitte einen leitpfosten und
vergesse ich das aber mit glöckchen und
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen uns auf jeder zeit und
eine spende von euch mit der er uns
hilft dieses projekt weiterzuführen denn
paper link dazu findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video was gut
und bis bald
[Musik]